في المرة الأولى التي قابلت فيها الملكة ، أعتقد أنني كنت
قد أمضيت بضعة أشهر فقط في دوري
وكانت حساسة جدًا لحقيقة
أنني كنت جديدًا ويمكنها أن تخبرني أنك
تعلم
أنني لم أكن متأكدًا جدًا من نفسي وقد
سألتها  أنت تعرف
نصيحتها وقد أخبرتني كم
هو مهم أن تكون دائمًا هناك
ليكون لديك هذا الإحساس بالواجب
والانضباط للانتباه إلى
التفاصيل الصغيرة وكنت دائمًا آخذ
نصيحتها على محمل الجد
بالنسبة لي لقد كانت خدمة عامة  تجسدت
أنك تعرف أنها امرأة تعهدت
بحياتها لخدمة شعبها ولم
تفشل أبدًا في الوفاء بهذا الوعد لمدة 70 عامًا
وأنت تعلم أعتقد
اليوم أنك تعرف أنها
كانت ملكة إنجلترا لكنها كانت أيضًا
رمزًا  ملكة العالم هي
تعني شيئًا لنا جميعًا
وبغض النظر عن هويتك ، فأنت تشعر بإحساس
اللانهاية والقرب منها ،
لقد صُدمت بالجو
الذي أعتقده
والحشود والجمهور البريطاني وأولئك
من  أنت تعرف من حول العالم
اغتنم الفرصة للمجيء إلى هنا ، فأنت تعلم أن هذا النوع من التلاقي سويًا ، انظر لقد مرت سنوات صعبة بالنسبة للمملكة المتحدة ، كما تعلم أه تحاول التفاوض على صفقة مع أوروبا بعد خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي جائحة كان تضخم تكلفة المعيشة صعبًا ولكن لم أشعر أبدًا بشعور العمل الجماعي الذي أشعر به اليوم في المملكة المتحدة ، لذلك كانت قوة موحدة فيها خلال حياتها لكنها أيضًا تتوحد في وفاتها اليوم ، فقد ذكّرت الناس بما يعنيه أن تكون بريطانيًا ، فقد أعطت الجميع إحساسًا من المنظور ، كان من المشجع جدًا أن نرى كيف اجتمع الجميع ، حيث أن السياسيين من جميع الجوانب لديهم نوع من الصفوف المغلقة حول ملكهم الجديد واليوم نحن نحزن على الحياة ولكننا نحتفل أيضًا بالحياة ونحتفل ببداية فصل جديد لهذا البلد وأنا متفائل جدًا بمدى أهمية هذه العائلة المالكة للهاشميين ، فالعلاقة تعود إلى عدة عقود وتمتد إلى عدة أجيال جلالة الملك الحسين وجلالة الملك.  وصلوا إلى العرش في عام
1952 وتمتعوا بما
يقرب من 50 عامًا من الصداقة الحميمة
التي جعلتهم أكثر خصوصية من خلال تجربتهم المشتركة
كملوك ورث زوجي
الملك عبد الله
هذه
العلاقة واعتز
بها ، كما كان مغرمًا جدًا بجلالتها كما كان
من المستحيل ألا أكون ولدينا
علاقة وثيقة جدًا مع جلالته
وحفل الملكة كاميلا
، وابني الآن قريب جدًا من الأمير
ويليام ، لذا فهي علاقة
تمتد أه
عبر الأجيال وهي
علاقة نتمسك بها حقًا لأن  إنها تستند إلى
القيم المشتركة ، كما تعلم ، فقد خدم زوجي
في الجيش البريطاني أيضًا وتخرج ابني
أيضًا من ستانفورد ، لذا
تعلم أنه متعدد الأوجه
ويعود إلى فترة طويلة جدًا في عهد
جلالتها خلال فترة كانت فيها
نهاية الاستعمار أم شوهدت
وهناك
احترام للنظام الملكي البريطاني
متشابك مع بعض القضايا التي أتت
من تلك الحقبة كيف
ترى علاقة دي؟  إن تطوير
جلالتها كان دائمًا
بقيادة المدير وكان على استعداد لتغيير
وتعديل السياسات كما هي مناسبة جدًا ، لذا
أعتقد أن الناس يفهمون أن مكانة
النظام الملكي اليوم مختلفة تمامًا
عن القضايا المقابلة لها عما كانت عليه في كل
عصر  ظروفها الخاصة
والمضي قدمًا كما قلت إن صاحب
الجلالة لديه فهم عميق
لمنطقتنا ، وهو احترام عميق للملكة ،
ولديه أيضًا إعجاب عميق
باهتمامه بالإسلام الذي
أعتقد أنه مهم حقًا لأننا
نفكر في العلاقة التي
تتمتع بها الملكية البريطانية  مع
الشرق الأوسط والمنطقة الأوسع أم الخليج
للمضي قدمًا تمامًا لأنه
شخص مدروس للغاية فهو شخص
يعرف الأشياء ويدرس الأشياء بعمق ،
لذلك عندما يتعامل مع
العالم الإسلامي يتعامل معه
بشعور من الفروق الدقيقة و  إحساس
بالخبرة والمعرفة لذلك فهو يعرف
المنطقة جيدًا ويعرف حقًا
كيف يتنقل أه
إنه رجل حكيم جدًا ولا أشك في
ذهني  إلى أي مدى سيعزز
العلاقات ليس فقط مع الجزء الخاص بنا من
العالم ولكن مع كل جزء من العالم